nouvelle mobilisation aujourd'hui à
paris près de 200 chauffeur vtc
manifestent actuellement leur
mécontentement place de l'hôtel de ville
ils dénoncent la discrimination
pratiquée selon par la maire de paris en
faveur des chauffeurs de taxi en cause
la rue de rivoli réservé depuis le 11
mai au vélo bus taxis et véhicules
d'artisans une mesure qui pourrait être
pérennisée anne hidalgo doit les
recevoir à 17 heures nous demandons à
madame hidalgo d'avoir le droit tout au
même titre que les taxis d'utiliser les
voies de bus car aujourd'hui nous
transportons pour ma société en
l'occurrence trente mille touristes par
mois vers les hôtels parisiens en
provenance des aéroports
donc la moindre des choses c'est au même
titre que les taxis d'utiliser les voies
de bus en tant que professionnel tout
simplement
c'est le seul droit qu'on demande on
aimerait justement aider la mairie et
non pas aller en contre elle mais les
dés justement à à à se projeter sur un
avenir de paris sans voitures mais je ne
pense pas entre nous qui avec 10000 taxi
à l'heure actuelle dans paris elles
puissent le faire exactement et
correctement mais c'est simple si vous
passiez aujourd'hui à vtc sur sa journée
on va dire qu'il est sur un chiffre
d'affaires entre 300 et 400 euros tout
par rapport à la catégorie de véhicules
qu'il est je vous laisse faire le
chiffre si vous prenez une amende de 135
euros sur un chiffre d'affaires de 350
les calculs sont vite faits